[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where the Kennedy family and we've been
in New Zealand this nearly 12 years this
year we first moved to the north island
in Taranaki and have worked our way
steadily down the country until we now
live in ranga and why Machiavelli we've
met some great people and it's a great
place to live we really feel like we've
made the right decision in where we live
at the moment it's fantastic we took it
very seriously making the decision one
that it was was right for us and you
know we like the country we've been made
to feel really welcome and it is now our
home and the fact that that we've set it
as our home than we thought we'd be take
the next step and become citizen and
we've been very lucky today to have this
London Waitangi day and get them awry
it's been really good we fill it we're
feel really privileged actually
saying the words receiving receiving the
certificate it's quite special if
something will never forget
[Music]